you can't help but love bees once you
get introduced to them you know they're
warm and fuzzy it sounds like Teddy
Bears but honestly it really is like
that and once you get to know them you
want to take care of the bees because
they're really taking care of the earth
and and ultimately us
[Music]
Savannah Bee Company is a company that
the mechanism is we sell honey and honey
based beauty products and Mead honey
wine but what we really do is we're
trying to raise awareness about bees how
important they are we want to really
save the bees
for every single pound of honey there
are two million flowers that get
pollinated the more you learn about bees
you just become enthralled with how
amazing they are what they do
this is one thing that really got me
loving honey is just the different kind
of colored types of honey
[Music]
climate change is definitely impacting
our company and and beekeepers all over
when a flower opens it's got to have the
right temperature and humidity and
enough rain but not too much rain not
too dry not too hot not too cold and you
can imagine with this like huge
variations in in weather patterns how
that could affect that we depend on One
Tree the Tupelo tree that blooms for
just 10 days in April and if everything
doesn't line up there's no nectar in the
flower for the bees to make the honey
and since 2008 you know we've had maybe
one out of five years It's Been a Good
Year where it used to be you might have
one out of five years it was a bad year
so overall globally beekeepers in
certain regions wrestle with honey
production in a huge way
foreign
project we had in the Bahamas the island
of Exuma and they sort of picked up the
bat phone and said we don't have any
bees and could you help us with that so
we went spent a year looking for bees
honeybees couldn't find any so trained
beekeepers they built equipment and then
we flew bees down so 11 Queens 33 pounds
of worker bees we flew them down in
there put them in their their boxes and
that was in 2015 and today there's
hundreds of beehives about a dozen
beekeepers they I think there's six
different honey labels that they sell
all over the Bahamas and maybe a little
bit around the Caribbean and the bees
are Mite free disease free and they're
making honey like the good old days and
it's just a great successful project
the B calls project might be our
greatest Legacy it's a not-for-profit
that we started after we put one
observation Hive in a school so an
observation beehive is sort of a glass
or a window Hive which allows you know
anyone not just a beekeeper but anybody
to look inside you know the mechanisms
and operations of honey bee hives these
bees that are wiggling they're telling
the other bees where they found the
nectar or the pollen we've grown from
you know one to 750 hives they're in
media centers they're in science rooms
they're in hallways they're in the
entrance to the school it's all over the
map you got to save the bees and in the
process you'll end up saving the planet